- Alright, so I always
enjoy ending the show
with something fun, or something I love.
And today I am bringing you both.
This is what I'm liking.
So back in March, I
paired up with Snoop Dogg
to bring a version of
Eurovision Song Contest
here to the US, it was an amazing show.
And for the past few months,
we've seen incredible artists
from all 50 states, five US
territories and Washington, D.C.
and it was just really cool
to see everybody representing
all these different territories or states
that you maybe didn't know a lot about
musically or culturally.
And the songs were incredible.
And I've loved seeing so much diversity
in the genres and all these artists.
And a couple days ago,
a jury of their peers
and you, America, crowned a winner.
She seemed unstoppable from the start
with her song, "Wonderland".
Here is Oklahoma's K-Pop queen, Alexa,
in her winning moment.
- [Announcer] That means Oklahoma
is the first ever winner
of American Song Contest.
Congratulations to Alexa and Oklahoma!
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] Come on over here
Alexa, come get your award!
(audience cheering)
- Oh man, I was, like, so busy
hosting, I missed the moment,
and thanks to that win you will see her
at the Billboard Music Awards Sunday,
but we have her here now.
Everybody say hi to Alexa.
(audience cheering)
So is that, were you just like so floored?
Did you think -
'cause there were so many
talented people there,
and it was like apples and oranges, like,
comparing all these artists.
- Exactly. Exactly. I mean,
even from when just the first
qualifier episode started,
everybody had their own
little, like, flavor,
their own little spice to them.
It was kind of hard to choose,
you know, who could win.
Everybody could, it was
anybody's game honestly.
But with that whole result
being announced last night,
it was just so emotional 'cause
my mom, my dad was there.
My team all the way from
Korea was there as well.
We had someone from Germany
fly in from our team.
It was just very emotional.
- I love it.
And I know I told you this
the other day on the carpet
when we were after the show,
talking to all the photographers
and the news outlets and everything,
but it was funny 'cause
the very first text
I got about this show was from Shelton,
that I work with on "The Voice".
And he was like, there's a girl
singing K-Pop from Oklahoma?
And he was like, he was like, wait, what?
And that's what I loved about
it. I thought it was so cool.
Especially you winning, 'cause
I think we think we know
what every state is like,
and every person in it,
and what they listen to,
and like, we do that.
We diminish people's like, you know,
versatility and love of
music or the arts in general,
or anything.
And I thought it was so cool
that you came from Oklahoma
and then you ended up just
dominating this competition.
The performance is incredible.
Your voice is incredible.
The dancing was super cool.
Anyway, thank you for being
just such a positive influence
for everybody out there,
but also just such a fiery performer
that really inspires other performers.
That's what I thought was so cool.
All you artists were so
supportive of each other.
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] It wasn't like you were fighting
to see who was better.
- We were so close.
- You were really like
dancing and singing.
Everybody was cheering everybody on,
it was a really cool vibe, yeah.
- [Alexa] Thank you so much, Kelly.
- Yeah. Congratulations.
- [Alexa] Thank you.
- [Kelly] Get sleep.
- I will tonight, thank you.
- Well, thank you Alexa.
I'm liking those posts right now.
So, usually at this point in the show,
we give our guests $1000 courtesy
of our season-long partner
Pilot Pen, makers of Frixion,
the go-to erasable pen at
"The Kelly Clarkson Show".
But she got a great life right now.
I figured maybe today it's gonna
be someone in the audience.
So maybe you wanna look under your chair.
Maybe you're the one with
$1000, I'm just saying.
Who's got it? Who's got it?
No one had it?
(Elon screaming)
(audience cheering)
- Yes! Okay!
- (laughing) Oh my God. Oh my God.
I was like, oh my God, what's
your name, where are you from?
- Hi, my name is Elon. I just
relocated here from Miami.
- Oh, awesome!
Well have so much fun
and go on a little
shopping spree, all right?
- Thank you.
- Just, you know, be careful. Liability.
Don't hit anyone with that chair.